so we've teamed up with local
organizations to help our great school
supply drive
is now underway bianca holman shares how
you can get involved
from clorox wipes to markers these are
various things that we're collecting for
our grade eight school supply drive to
help fill backpacks for kids
in need in addition to getting these
school supplies
vaccines that's also on family's to do
list
health officials are urging parents to
take care of mandatory shots and the
coven 19 vaccine at the same time
in clark county kids are going into
kindergarten and 7th grade will need to
get certain vaccinations
the southern nevada health district is
offering many of the required shots as
well as the copen 19 vaccine for
students 12
and older at various schools throughout
august getting the coven 19 vaccine
ahead of time
can prevent kids from missing school in
case they have a mild reaction and need
to stay home
i was just tired of not being able to be
in super close proximity with my friends
and i wanted
to be able to move on and like really
focus on my studies not to worry about
anything else
they may be sore for a day or two it may
not feel great for the next day
yet another reason you may want to start
the series before they go back to school
so they miss less days of school
you can drop off any of these school
supplies and backpacks at any smith's
location
across the valley from henderson to
north las vegas and las vegas
reporting bianca holman 8 news now